how to replace exams fairly
that's the question and now we know the
government's answer
this year the grades will be given by
teachers
with so much missed learning it's still
a stressful time for students
i'm quite concerned about how
my teachers will assess my grades
because some teachers i didn't have
last year and so i feel like that
opinion on me might be different
the idea of doing exams was much too
overwhelming after we'd missed so much
school
and i was already so demotivated i just
don't think that personally i could have
sat an exam and got the grade that i
deserved
i think because there's no algorithm
it'll be definitely better
i myself feel that i trust my teachers
i've worked closely with them over the
last two years and i've tried my best in
exams
that algorithm caused chaos last summer
leaving many students downgraded even
missing places at university
it was eventually ditched but the damage
had already been done
here's what's happening this year
teachers will submit grades to exam
boards by june the 18th
students then find out results from the
9th of august
that's two weeks earlier than normal and
provides a period for students to appeal
ministers say their plan offers fairness
and flexibility
the problem last year was the system
wasn't
fair and it led to a last minute u-turn
both of these things added huge stress
and anxiety to students
and that's something everyone wants to
avoid this time
the head teacher in this north london
school welcomes
trust being given to teachers because we
know our students
we can look at what evidence we need to
give them the best
possible grade to give them the best
possible chance
i think it overall i think it will work
well for teachers and it will work well
for young people
but there are still significant concerns
about the lack of detail
unions question the reliability and
consistency of grades
if schools use different methods they
think the government's made a serious
error of judgment and others fear there
remains a risk of excessive grade
inflation
which could devalue the credibility of
this year's results
laura bundock sky news